in the New York Times yesterday Thomas
Friedman wrote that instead of prattling
on about issues like jobs are the great
economy the media should spotlight
Trump's evil personality because that
will help the Democrats by discouraging
Republicans from backing Trump he wrote
quote the whole country needs to see
every tweet every rally every word in
every reaction so that they can ask
themselves is this who I want my kids to
see as our president what a great idea
because remember what happened the last
time the media covered every tweet every
rally every word in every reaction of
Donald Trump when when every wink nudge
cough became part of the media snark
NATO they elected Donald Trump the bozos
yep there were like 300 Republican
candidates but all the Yahoo's in the
press chased the orange meteor precisely
for the things they hate about him now
Trump was great TV he was shocking screw
Rick Perry Rand Paul and all those other
nobodies this guy makes chance into a
sure thing
Trump got like a billion dollars worth
of free air time and not led by Fox News
who actually featured commentators who
challenged Trump over his behavior and
beliefs
it was CNN who led the charge and
assorted other drips who didn't seem to
mind because they thought Hillary had it
in the bag anyway and then they had no
other way to get people to watch their
boring mindless coverage so telling the
media to focus on Trump's behavior
you're in effect saying hey remember how
we elected Trump in 2016 let's do it
again
isn't that true Morgan it seems like
Friedman has amnesia the more you the
more you focus on Trump the better he
does I think it's interesting this
advice is coming from people who it's
like the most boring dinner party ever
if you if you're with them like they're
having a glass of expensive wine and
they're like in trouble and so that's
essentially you're having people that
have no understanding of social media
and of how the president actually goes
straight to the American people
advocating for the media covering him in
general I mean this is this plays
directly into his playbook as you said
and I think listen I was I was on the
other side of him in the primary so I
know what it's like to for him to get
all the media coverage he did it
brilliantly he speaks directly to the
American people and I don't
know what Friedman thinks he's doing but
I think the same people who read this in
The Times
are the same people who sit with him at
their boring dinner parties and complain
about the president would you work for
in the primary job there are a lot of
people at Fox who are on the other side
so that's I mean and the thing is well I
was watching the amount of coverage on
CNN and going you know they're doing
everything not just CNN but MSNBC
Morning Joe should have been morning
Trump absolutely unlike Fox & Friends
I love Fox and Friends I'm up every
morning who should I talk to next Jason
I'm looking at your face and I'm
thinking what's in your brain what are
you thinking is it good to get personal
one of the biggest disappointments were
when I came into Congress in 2008 when I
got to the end is the lack of objective
media and I've seen how they totally
change the rules because things that
they wouldn't cover under Barack Obama
they now want to cover incessantly with
yeah with with Donald Trump they have
totally flipped the equation and to be
in a contrived way actually advocating
hey look this is what we need to do so
we can all get together on the same page
yes it's so contrived there are very few
media outlets that I really trust on
that you know when you were going to
read the paper in the morning people
always asked I think the Wall Street
Journal gives it the fairest straightest
objective viewpoint but you know gone
are the days of a New York Times or
somebody like that that will objectively
actually give you just the straight up
now you know I believe that's owned by
our parent company I am a subscriber I
steal your paper that between 2000 and
2008 it was this the same yeah I mean
this is when the media like they have to
fight against President Bush on
everything every issue every utterance
every was amplified and then as Greg has
pointed out that they were asleep during
the Obama years Obama time but I do this
is what I think that there has been some
journalism that has had an effect on the
Trump administration if you look at the
HHS formers HHS Secretary Tom Price he
had to resign after that reporting the
New York Times and others mainly the New
York Times focusing on Scott Pruett at
the EPA that was journalism that didn't
that they didn't focus on President Ron
they were just doing their journalism
and they had in effect I would also say
that they spend so did Pruitt Pruitt had
in effect that's why they went after him
I mean he was doing some good stuff you
can do like good policy without without
the other which Andy Kessler is doing
now if they cover every tweet in every
utterance then they're not covering all
the other stuff so there's limited room
in the newspaper and if they just want
to do the tweets they can do that and
all the other stuff goes under the radar
yeah what people like Tom Freeman who's
the bright guy but he's dead wrong on
this well you have a better mustache
what they don't get is that Trump is a
movie star he's got charisma you
mentioned Jeb Bush I like Jeb a lot I
mean I had injury and a bunch of times
when he was governor but next to trump
it was like he had it was vanilla next
to a banana split with the Cheerios one
by one through the primary and just
everybody else and because they couldn't
compete with someone with that kind of
charisma now you can hate Trump you can
love Trump but the thing is there is
there is a magnetism about him the more
you see him and he doesn't blow the
world up you say hey you know maybe it's
not so bad the economy is ok it really
good and impact and we're not at war
with North Korea and they may may work
out their Iranian what if they don't
have to really hurt us and the more he's
around I think the more people get used
to him I think it really works in
Trump's favor but is it's what's
surprising to me about the piece is that
Friedman's sort of he put it out there
that that the media is not for the
president he sort of said the media
should against the president he was
honest is he admitting that the fake
news that the time he was honest and he
said I wish we could be China for a day
yeah all sorts have done things done
everybody went after him for saying oh
you really yeah every now and then he
lets it slip he pulls back the curtain
and we see what we really know to be
true all right